Welcome, Tom, to Microsoft Research. And it's great having you here
as part of giving your distinguished lecture tomorrow at Microsoft Research AI.
Just getting going about some of your background and interests, just
curious how you got interested in machine learning to begin with.
You started out in Oberlin. And were you always interested
in mechanism and machines, or how did you get going into AI?
Well, I guess I was always interested in kind of
engineering things. I had an uncle who was an MIT Ph.D.,
who worked in numerical controlled billing machines. And then he was one of the early people,
he was working for General Electric on the Dartmouth Time-Sharing System.
So, as a young kid I got chance to write in basic on a Teletype,
Interviewer: How did he end up giving you time on this machine,
over at dinner?
Yeah. But, then, so I was always doing computing.
And in those days when you applied to college you said,
well, what computer do they have? Because they would have only one,
right? So, Oberlin had an IBM 360 model 54 as well as a Ristas 11 PDP-8,
or maybe it was PDP-11. So I really wasn't -- I considered many majors
along the way. I was always taking a lot of math because that was fun.
But one of the ones I considered was political science.
And one of the classes in political science was philosophy of political science.
And my professor instructed me to read Thomas Kuhn's "Structure of Scientific
Revolutions" because he said Karl Marx claimed that he was a scientist,
Marx did. And here's what Thomas Kuhn thinks science is. What do you think? Which was very
Interviewer: He had all these interesting ideas about big scientific paradigm shifts.
Paradigm shifts, but the instrumentability of vocabulary and some of
subjectivism that maybe Marx also advocated.>> Interviewer: So,
I'm getting lost now. How did this get into AI?
In any case, when I decided to at least get a masters in computer science and I went to Illinois.
And I was offered a research assistantship by Ryszard Michalski.
And it was about what we now call machine learning.
But in my spare time I was hanging out in the philosophy library,
reading about the philosophy of science because I thought,
well, if I'm going to be doing this machine learning stuff I should
be trying to understand how is it that we learn about the world.
And what are the sort of foundational principles.
And so that led me into a lot of these kind of questions about
Interviewer: Confirmation theory and Carnap.
Carnap, yes. And then sort of, I don't know, through a connection with Donald Michie,
I was introduced to Bruce Buchanan, who lo and behold, was a philosopher of science.
And so then he offered me a research position as a graduate student at Stanford.
And so these things kind of snowballed. But while I was still a masters student at Illinois,
Tom Mitchell and Jaime Carbonell and Ryszard organized the first
machine learning workshop which was at CMU in the summer of 1980.
And all 20 of us or whatever were in the room. And so that was -- they decided to
revive the term that Arthur Samuel had chosen of machine learning as being the name
Interviewer: I didn't realize that Arthur Samuel chose that phrase.
Yeah, I think one of the titles in one of his first papers is some studies
on the game of checkers or something like that.>> Interviewer:
Some of the early work in machine learning that I've read over the years really
seems to have laid out the whole architecture of modern machine learning quite early,
like in the early '60s in fact. Some great work was done.
Well, especially if you go to, say, Nils Nilsson had this book "Learning Machines," 1967 maybe.
and Hart, I think, particularly. What a beautiful book they wrote.>> Interviewer: You mentioned that,
somewhere I saw you mention that you have research attention disorder.
disorder, yes.>> Interviewer: Attention deficit disorder. I guess it's like,
I think people that are the most fun in the field seem to be intellectually promiscuous. In other words,
they're not going to dance around with attention deficit,
but they go deep in several different areas over time,
and they make links among those areas. And I always think that's kind of an interesting thing to,
as a way to do science.
I mean, I think you also maybe suffer from it.>> Interviewer: Or enjoy it.
But, or enjoy it, yes. I find basically all of these,
sort of every aspect of artificial intelligence is fascinating.
And I've also always wanted to have one foot in some sort of an application setting, because, of course,
we came of age kind of maybe in reaction to the artificial intelligence of
1965 to 1975, which was all about the blocks world and kind of toy problems.
And it was pretty clear that things that worked on those problems didn't really work on anything else.
And I like to think of the history of artificial intelligence as the period of the
known knowns when it was fully determined (indiscernible) observed systems.
And then we had the known unknowns period of (indiscernible) and
probabilistic reasoning over fully observable things more or less.
And then we've moved now into the unknown knowns of how do we give systems that really work in open
computer does not have a full model of what's going on.>> Interviewer: In fact,
I think you've pointed out that having a full model in a world with, by definition,
limited datasets is actually desired for the fundamental theorem of machine learning.
Right. Because, yes, in machine learning we have learned
that if we don't have enough data then we have to use a --
models.>> Interviewer: You want to do that.
Yes, in order to get the best, say, performance, classification, accuracy or predictive accuracy.
And this is something that's deeply disturbing. If you've been raised kind of in
the realist philosophy of science which says there's a real reality out there.
The electrons really exist, for instance, even though we can't observe them, and our goal is to understand that.
But if you come from the instrumentalist community, which is where Bruce Buchanan brought me up to be,
we're really interested in sciences is important as it is useful to
we really care about.>> Interviewer: Now,
you and I know, we've had deeply shared interests in AI and the open world and
the implications of limitations in the technology in terms of influences on AI,
people and society more broadly. And you've done some really fascinating
review work and some deep dives into what it will take to build robust AI,
what we're up against in trying to achieve robustness in our AI systems as we field them in the open world.
And you had a few ideas, like the idea of open category learning, for example.
And just want you to make some comments on where you are with that.
So, I mean, this began with an application problem. I was working
with ecologists and people at the Environmental Protection Agency,
and they wanted to assess the health of freshwater streams in the United States.
And one way they do that is to sample the bugs that live in those streams.
So it turns out if you have an insect larvae that may live for a month
in a stream, it's in some sense drinking the water the whole time.
And so if it's alive and healthy then that's a pretty good sign that the stream is healthy.
So we had collected specimens -- well, our collaborators had collected 100
specimens each of 54 different species of these kind of indicator insects,
and we built a computer vision system that could automatically recognize them. We
were very excited when it was 92 percent correct on 54 classes until we found out,
well, if we were dealing with real field samples, they would
contain a lot of other stuff besides our 54 species,
because there are something like 2,000 species of insects that live in the rivers, not to mention
insect-shaped leaves and little stones and things that might fool the computer vision system.
And our system failed miserably when it was shown these -- we call them aliens now -- but these new,
at least new to the computer, species of insects. So that
really motivated me to think about this open category work.
Can you describe for people watching this video what the open category challenge is?
The open category challenge is that I've taught my
computer to tell the difference among these 54 species,
but someone at test time shows me a thing and says, what is it.
And the standard way that we train a machine learning system,
it really only knows, it thinks there are only 54 types of things in the
universe. So, if you stick your thumb into the camera and photograph it,
it would assign it to one of those 54 categories. Now it
might say, well, I can't decide whether it's this or that.
But it never enters its mind, so to speak, that there might
be something else out there. And so the question is,
how could we have a computer system that knows that it doesn't know everything? So it knows
that it knows these 54 things but there are potentially thousands of other things out there.
And so it entertains that explicitly as a possibility.
And so our strategy has been to say for the computer --
so when we train the computer system, the standard way is to ask it kind of like when training a
physician: What are the key differences that would let you tell that this is a this versus that?
If you ever tried to recognize bird species you know you're supposed to look for a red dot above the eye.
Or if you're learning to tell poisonous mushrooms from delicious
mushrooms, you maybe want to look for gills or something.
And the same thing is true for these insects.
But the end result is that the computer has learned to make these fine
distinctions, but it doesn't really know what the whole insect looks like.
It's just looking for that red dot and not for everything else. We
instead want to have the computer learn models of that sort of,
just give it a sense of what each of these species really looks like so that when it sees my thumb it says,
well, that doesn't look like anything that I saw in my training
data, so I refuse to assign it to one of my 54 categories,
going to hand it to Eric here who is an expert and he'll tell me what it is.>>
Interviewer: It's interesting to think about all the things we can do to give our
systems either explicit or implicit knowledge that the world is bigger than they are,
much, much bigger, and so they're ready to deal with being
humble about what they know and what they don't know.
I think you've also looked at this idea of how to do reinforcement
learning in a safe way or think deeply about missing exogenous variables,
for example.
Right. So that came up more in, not so much that the exogenous variables are missing,
of course, because they're exogenous.
So, I mean, this isn't really my own work, but I
have looked at, as you say, I've been serving literature,
and there's some very nice work by Simon Orr and his students where they -- one
intuition I think we all have is that in situations where we know that we're ignorant,
we should probably act more conservatively and carefully. And it turns out we can make
this precise mathematically and show that if we minimize downside risk so that in,
when we're training reinforcement learning systems we typically
look at like the expected reward or the expected return.
And you might be looking at that if you're investing in stocks on Wall Street, too. You might say,
well, I want to choose a mutual fund that has a high
expected return, and that's what they advertise in fact.
But maybe really, particularly as you get older, you might be concerned about downside risk.
You might say, I want to invest in a mutual fund that maybe it doesn't get the highest overall risk,
but the probability that I'll lose more than 50 percent of my funds, they like drive that near zero.
And so it turns out that we can show that that kind of a notion that I
want to limit my downside risk is equivalent to dealing with average,
maximize my average return when I'm uncertain of the dynamics of the world. So this does confirm
in a mathematical way that it's good to be conservative when you don't know how the world works.
So you've recently been weighing in on this
discussion which is evolving just maybe the last year or two.
But it goes back a long ways about innate knowledge, innate
structure, innate algorithms that intelligent systems might have,
harkening back to human beings and going from toddlers into adulthood. What's
the innate abilities that we have and how do we learn on top of that?
And there's various approaches to this. And I think you've been talking about your own perspective lately
or you at least raised questions about this in terms of this idea of a minimal system that we might build
some day that would do life long learning and become brilliant in the world and be able to do well.
Any thoughts, your current thoughts on this discussion?
So there are certainly, a significant portion of the AI research community and also, I think,
the general public, when they think about artificial intelligence they think about something that would
be an artificial human being or something that would have the same breadth of knowledge as people do,
whereas our current AI systems are always extremely narrow. You cannot overemphasize how
are.>> Interviewer: I call these things sort of brilliant savants.
I don't throw the word "idiot" out too often, but narrow savants.
They're very, very narrow. And that's a system we seem to know how to build right now.
And so how does this connect to innateness? I guess we observe in people
that they do come into the world with some degree of innate knowledge.
We can't interview them to find out what it is. But they can do these studies on infants
Interviewer: Certainly toddlers seem to have way more breadth even --
Yes. And (indiscernible) systems can come close to a three-year-old in terms
Yeah, that could be. So, it's not really my area of expertise. But
certainly there are these studies and also studies on other animal species.
So, we know many animals are born almost like adults. Obviously
a horse can already stand and walk immediately after birth,
whereas humans need an adult human to hang on for a year
before they really are, even start to be able to walk.
So one lesson you might take from that is one of the things that's
allowed humans to be more broad is that we are born with less built-in,
prewired knowledge. And if we want AI systems -- so this is
kind of the paradox is that in order to get our narrow systems,
even our narrow systems to work we build in a ton of prior
knowledge into them. There's a huge amount of innate knowledge,
although it's often not explicit. I mean, innate knowledge
is not like that they've memorized the times tables.
It's more that there's some set of constraints so that when those constraints combine with
experiences that the system has then it's able to rapidly do well in that narrow area.
And one big thing that we would like to do is have our AI systems be broader. A lot of the
mistakes that our AI systems make right now are because they are so narrow that they might --
I mean, we saw this case recently of the -- I think it was BMW
that had this self-driving car system that they had trained,
and then they took it to Australia and it was being fooled by the motions
of kangaroos. It had never really seen kangaroos hopping around before.
And so that was an example that was just too narrow in one particular way and it couldn't deal with this broader thing.
But also I think when we look at a lot of these ethical challenges of AI systems, where
we're making misclassification errors that are really offensive to some people,
the computer is completely oblivious to the fact that some people might be insulted by being misclassified.
Or it could be very insensitive, for instance, to be positioning advertisements
for funeral homes opposite news stories about car crashes or something.
Why would our customers be upset with that? It's because the computer system knows nothing about
Yes, right. So, we'd definitely like our computer systems to be much broader. But to do
that we need to be building in less or building in different kind of innate knowledge into them,
because we know that if you try to learn starting with nothing, then it
will basically take you an infinite amount of data to learn things.
So there's a very tight tradeoff there between the amount of experience we need and the amount of
to build into the system.>> Interviewer: You've been through many different,
we'll call them dominant paradigms, back to Kuhn, of machine learning, going
from certainty factors and heuristic methods to probabilistic ethical models,
and now we're in this area of deep learning, these generalized
function learning with differentiation and optimization.
What is your sense with where things are going in terms of the
rich semantics and the semantic foundations of learning systems?
It's been quite a ride. And I think also there's been a -- the pendulum swings
back and forth between whether we start with a formal understanding and then the experiments
follow or we start with the experiments and then the formal understanding follows.
And we're definitely in a period right now where there's this sort of crazy experimentation.
Well, yes, I call it a giant hack-a-thon, like the whole field
aided and abetted by the Internet and archiving and people just posting
papers and software frameworks and it's been an incredibly productive time,
I think, particularly surprising because we have all of these large corporate interests
And very competitive terrain yet there's a tremendous sharing of
the core tools and everybody's learning from everybody else very quickly.
So, I mean, I think right now deep learning is getting a lot of attention, but in parallel --
and why? Because it's given us an even more expressive set of functions or class of models,
a language that lets us be able to use machine learning to do things we couldn't do before.
And so that's -- and we -- and that really required, yes, coming up with
the language, which we kind of had from neural networks in the '90s,
but improved algorithms, much improved computation and vastly
improved data and all those things really coming together.
But those same factors are at work on the probabilistic modeling
side. So you sort of left off with latent variable models,
but then we had Bayesian nonparametrics, and now we have probabilistic programming.
And interestingly we now have probabilistic programming systems that are compiling to
the same TensorFlow infrastructure that the deep learning systems are compiling to.
And we're seeing lots of really interesting interplay between probabilistic reasoning, for instance,
about say the variational autoencoders and high, high dimensional density
estimation. I think there's some extremely exciting ideas happening there.
So this is using neural network type machinery but to do probabilistic
modeling, because I think ultimately we need to be able --
in order to understand and debug and ensure the safety of these AI
systems, make sure they're actually doing what we want them to,
we need able to understand what they've learned and the intermediate semantics.
And I think the only tool we have for that comes out of probability,
which gives us a declarative reading of what these variables mean, and it gives us the theory of identifiability
of the parameters and all these things that we don't get from the pure function learning approach.
On the other hand, the big lesson, I think, that we have
to take away from the function learning was that in,
in computer vision at least, right, we tried -- we know that to go from pixels all the way to saying,
oh, that is a person sucking on a lollypop or whatever, that is such a huge leap in
interpretation that we needed to have some intermediate representations along the way.
And we tried to hand-engineer those, and we had SIFT, our fellow graduate student, David Lowe,
had invented this, and Paul Viola and HOG and so on. And it turned out these deep learning things
could just learn those representations directly instead much better than we could do them by hand.
So we've learned that machine learning often can beat a human -- hand-engineering,
but particularly in that sort of signal-to-symbol transition area where we just --
we had no shortage of data, but we had this huge gap to cross. So
I think we will see a lot more hybridization of the techniques,
and I expect the higher level systems will look a lot more like probabilistic
programming and even logical or relational type representations.
But anything dealing with signal data, we now have this really powerful tool.
And who knows, we can do end-to-end training of these systems now if we can make all the components differentialable.
And several people are using this phrase differentialable programming to sort of describe what's going on,
that these are not unformed neural networks; people really think very carefully about
the ability of designing a skeletal program which is then filled in with data.
A pipeline where you could actually literally have a surface to optimize over.
And we have memory units and we have time series units.
All kinds of, again, innate things are being programmed in.
And both in the probabilistic frameworks and in these deep learning frameworks we
have much more expressive languages and ways of training and reasoning over them.
in Hamilton and Monte Carlo. This is just so cool.>> Interviewer: So, Tom,
you and I were involved in the 2008, 2009 AAAI panel of Long Term AI
Futures. And I think you actually cochaired one of the subcommittees,
I think it was on short-term disruptions. And back when we had
the meeting at Asilomar we had Andrew Ng get up and I asked him,
I gave him a challenge, and I said, to kick off this whole day at
Asilomar with this group thinking about of Long-Term AI Futures,
tell us what's going to surprise us. And he got up and gave, essentially if you look back on his talk,
he gave a deep learning talk, and that was in February of 2009.
Interviewer: And that summer we had the kind of like the first breakthrough,
I think, at Microsoft Research with speech. So if I asked you that again, now that we've
been through a few surprises with the power of deepnet to do object recognition and so on.
And I ask you this question now, what might surprise us, Tom, in the next five to ten years,
what comes to mind?
Well, one of the other things that we talked about in my group there at Asilomar was AI-enabled crime.
And we've just seen a very interesting report come out across several
organizations about potential misuses of the current AI technology.
And it's clear there are risks in cybersecurity. We now have the ability to create extremely high
quality fake video in which you and I could be saying absolutely outrageous terrible things,
which is sort of the automated fake news problem. So those, I'm
afraid we might have some very bad surprises along those lines,
because first of all we as people are kind of suckers for the interesting story
and the conspiracy theory and we've seen that at play in social media.
But also our institutions are not adapting as quickly as our algorithms are.
At the same time, I guess, a reason for hope there is we are aware of this, and many people
are scrambling to think about all of these ethical and social consequences of our systems.
And the industry even more maybe than the universities is deeply engaged
in this. And of course your leadership of the Partnership for AI,
I think, is going to be a key part of preparing us to move forward
Interviewer: How about technically though surprises?
What might be an upside in the technical breakthrough?
Well, I would like to say that we would have some beautiful breakthroughs in, say,
dialogue systems, that we could really have more than a one-step interaction with Cortana.
And I think we'll see some progress there. But again it's going to have to be narrow
because computer vision people like to say that anything can appear in an image.
And natural language people can say anything, you can talk about anything in speech. In fact,
unlike in images you can talk about abstract things -- ideas and trends and
paradigms. And our computer systems don't have any idea what those are.
And we don't know how to program those ourselves. And it's hard to
figure out how we're going to get the training data for that either.
We can't ground those the way we can with ImageNet or giant corpa. So I guess I'm not so optimistic,
but I do think that we can have much better conversations than we have now.
Another area that I think is going to be a huge opportunity is
to couple deep learning with all these problems in medicine.
Everything in medical imaging is in the middle being totally revolutionized because
these tools for deep learning that we've been using for entertainment on the Web are
now being transferred to understanding all of these complex images in medicine.
exciting, I think.>> Interviewer: Do you see implications for
the nature of work and human jobs versus what the machines do and so on?
What's your thinking about that?
Certainly there are some work, including, let's say, my physician
friends who describe their work as intellectual assembly line work.
There are some aspects of many knowledge-worker type jobs that we'll be able
to, I won't say automate necessarily but provide very good assistance.
But I don't think that we're going to see entire jobs go away.
I think jobs are going to be redefined so that some of the --
what was currently on the job description will now be something we can do very effectively with an AI tool.
And then other -- everything will rearrange as a result. And so I think
virtually every job category will probably be affected by some of these things,
just as the Internet and the Web, say, transform travel agents or
many other things. And yet I think there's so many things where --
anything that requires breadth, we know our computer systems
are going to continue to be narrow for a long time.
And so I think any job that requires breadth and integration of
information, dealing with humans and all of the human things,
I think are areas that are going to be critical. Stuart Russell used
to make this point in response to the skeptics about AI who would say,
you're just making simulations. He would say, when a computer
simulates playing chess, it's actually playing chess.
And we now have, it plays Go as well. I think it's always going to be true when
a computer simulates having emotions it's just simulating having emotions because
not being human it can't have any direct experience of human emotion.
So it's always just going to be struggling as an alien would struggle to understand us.
And so I think all of the job functions that involve negotiation and understanding
people and human experience are going to be very firmly in the place where humans
those.>> Interviewer: The way I like to think about this,
and I resonate deeply, is with the rise of automation around us, that
there will be even an amplification and a celebration of human touch,
human caring, maybe even the rise of a caring of human experience.
So you mentioned earlier about you like to get into applications,
not just theory via in the open world, both technically as well as making contributions there.
And you've done incredible work in this rising area that you
helped to define, we call computational sustainability now.
Talk more about how you got involved in the whole biological world and environment and applications there.
I think it's such an exciting and important space.
Yes, I guess I'd like to say it was a mid-career crisis,
because after I got my Ph.D. and I got tenure and so on,
and I was publishing lots of nice technical papers, but I didn't feel like
I was having enough impact in terms of problems that really mattered.
And one of those is the environment and the threats from climate change.
And so being at Oregon State University, it turns out, there's always a toss up between Oregon State and
as to who is number one in ecology.>> Interviewer: I missed out on that competition,
but I believe it.
It turns out like in forestry schools, ag schools. So they're
tremendous, wonderful collaborators to work with at Oregon State.
So I got involved gradually with several projects and we
started a training program, a Ph.D. training program,
in what we were calling at the time ecosystem informatics.
Although informatics maybe wasn't quite the right word,
because it was more simultaneously trying to support ecologist, ecological
scientists who are trying to understand how ecosystems function,
but also policymakers and, like the EPA or the forest service or farmers and
so on, who are actually managing an ecosystem trying to make it work.
And so building tools, helping -- giving them, really taking the modeling tools that we have from,
say, sequential decision-making and decision analysis and making it
possible for them to apply them to these challenging problems.
And so we also have, like, a summer training program and then we
got these large grants from the National Science Foundation.
And so then -- and one thing leads to another. So on the supporting ecological science side,
I got heavily involved with collaborating with the Cornell lab of ornithology. And
this brings us to another one of your favorite topics which is crowdsourcing.
There are many passionate birdwatchers in the world. And Cornell was one of the first organizations
to try to engage them in massive data collection efforts through something they called eBird,
where birdwatchers can go out, go for a two-hour hike maybe and
create a checklist of all the birds they saw along that hike.
And then they can upload that to a website. And we promised we were going to do science with that data.
But then it turned out to be tricky to do science with that data. And so I was one of many people
working then on how to take that data that was being collected and figure out could we fit,
could we understand bird habitat requirements, could we understand bird
migration, which happens at continental scales with billions of birds.
And so we've made some progress on those questions and it's been a load of fun.
And then on the policy side, I was looking at problems, say, in
wildfire management in the west or in invasive species management.
And there you have tight budgets and you have to carefully choose what actions to perform.
And you also have some serious risks -- massive fires or species extinctions or agricultural challenges.
interesting problems to work on.>> Interviewer: So now that you have comma emeritus after your name,
you might be in a position to give advice to folks who are just
starting out in their careers about what to look out for,
what to think about, what to reflect about, how to make decisions about a career in computer science.
So do you have any thoughts you want to share with young computer
scientists or people even thinking about computer science?
Well, I think it's important to focus on the
foundations, right. So, and that doesn't mean just taking,
like, the foundational classes in computer science, but more -- there's a temptation, I think,
and it's gotten very exaggerated lately in machine learning that
we jump immediately to coding up an experiment and running it.
And I think it's important to first consider what are the scientific hypotheses that you're testing.
Too much of experimental computer science has turned into demos rather than into really asking what are
the questions that we really need to answer in order to move our understanding of computing forward.
And then what experiments can I do to answer those questions? Really taking a scientific approach to
things rather than just trying to grab for the low-hanging fruit of whatever current paradigm is popular.
And it's tough because reviewers at conferences may be looking for what's hot right
now, and maybe they haven't thought about some of those other things for a while.
But I think you need a rutter that's heading you toward success in the long term. And I think --
and also part of that, I think, is keeping yourself honest by working
on real problems. And so nowadays the secret is collaboration.
You really need, particularly if you want to dive deep into a domain, you can't
simultaneously be an expert in the domain and an expert in computer science,
although you tried with an MD and Ph.D. But you really need to
find a collaborator who can also do that deep dive with you.
And they need to be willing to also learn some computer science. And you have to budget a
year or two just to learn the vocabulary of each other's fields and understand also the,
I say, social standards and morays, what counts as research result and how can you both succeed.
But the payoff then is that you can not only discover new and important computer science questions,
have an impact in those fields as well.>> Interviewer: You've been a fabulous advisor to so many students.
Your Web page has a big list of all the successful students that have done Ph.D.s with you.
Any advice for getting through a dissertation and the whole
process, just more practical on the practical side?
Yes. Well, first of all, it's normal to feel despair at various points in the Ph.D.,
and to feel that, I remember when I was stuck in my third year, which seemed to take two or three years,
decide what would my thesis be about.>> Interviewer: I think I met you in those years.
Yes, you did. I think I went through seven different topics
or something. Everything either seemed impossible or too easy.
And the lesson I learned was the "too easy" problems were also hard. So I think it's good to do --
Donald Knuth has this advice, first solve a problem that will take
you a minute, and then maybe one that will take you an hour,
and one that will take you a day, and one that you think will
take you a month, and one that ends up taking you a year,
and then you graduate.
So I think I have taught research methods and there's all these methods about how to do a statistical test correctly.
But I think the number one question of research methodology is, what do I do today when
I come into my office and sit down that is going to move me forward on this project?
And as long as you do something every day that does that, you'll move
Interviewer: And you probably won't feel so despaired.
Well, yes, but you just have to pace yourself and
realize that, yes, progress comes in small increments.
And you should have a back up plan because many things will fail along the way. So, you need a fall-back strategy;
all your eggs in one basket.>> Interviewer: Thanks, Tom. It's been great talking to you.
I've enjoyed it.
It's been a great pleasure. Thank you.